[Music]
hello you're watching the press preview
a first look at what is on the front
pages as they arrive it's time to see
what is making their headlines with
consultant editor at the daily mail
andrew pearce and associate editor of
the daily mirror kevin mcguire they'll
be with us from now until just before
midnight so let's take a look at what is
on some of those front pages with only
days left before we get a new prime
minister the eye is reporting that the
election front-runner liz trusts is
under increasing pressure from
conservatives to deliver immediate help
with rising fuel bills for households
and small businesses
the guardian is leading with a warning
from experts that children could die
this winter if their families are forced
to turn off their heating
well if liz trust does become pm next
week the telegraph reports that she's
considering scrapping motorway speed
limits and even the new smart motorways
the express says whoever wins they will
meet the queen to officially take up
their post at balmoral not buckingham
palace this is to save her majesty
travelling to london from scotland
the times leads with a new study which
has found that nearly half of british
children now grow up outside the
traditional two-parent household with a
big rise in lone parenting
financial times are reporting that some
factories in germany have had to stop
production after russia halted gas
supplies through the nordstrom one
pipeline
the metro leads with the abuse trial of
former footballer ryan giggs ending with
the jury
ending with the jury not reaching any
verdicts he may now face a re-trial and
if he does it will be next year
and finally the tsar has a somewhat
suggestive headline about what caused
the royal navy's aircraft carrier the
prince of wales to break down at sea
i'll let you read that i couldn't
possibly say it out loud
now a reminder that by scanning the qr
code on your screen during this program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers yourself while you
watch us talking about them
and as i said we are joined tonight by
consultant editor at the daily mail
andrew pearce and associate editor of
the daily mirror kevin mcguire hello to
you both hi there
yeah very good thank you and what should
we start with should we start with the i
um and obviously energy dominating so
many uh headlines over recent weeks and
months um and this is the conservative
party really putting liz trust under a
bit of pressure because of course she is
the overwhelming favorite to become
prime minister next week and it's all
about immediate action families up and
down the country have waited long enough
come monday they want to see some action
andrew yeah they won't get it quite on
monday i'm afraid because of the way
this is going to work out she won't
actually be installed properly as prime
minister until tuesday
um there'll be a privy council meeting
on wednesday but there'll be an
emergency cabinet meeting i imagine
she's already worked out her cabinet
sarah jane who's got the big jobs anyway
we pretty much knows with chancellor
quasi quarten and we know also that
she's been working flat out in chiefly
that's the official residence of the
foreign secretary on an emergency plan
to deal with the energy crisis uh the
the cap is lifted uh in 81 85 our bills
are going to go up in october so they've
got to have a clear plan in place
immediately and i think it will be there
now whether it's going to be enough
that's another question but what's quite
interesting in the eye they're saying
that some tory mps are concerned that
she's only going to be concerned about
the fabled red wall the seats which
boris johnson captured from the labour
party which had been labor heartland for
many years and he captured them by sheer
force of his personality and that phrase
get brexit done backbenchers have told
the eye she only cares about the red
wall she doesn't care about the blue
wall these are the seats in the
southeast the southwest very vulnerable
to the lib dems and they're very worried
that they're going to be sacrificed on
the altar of the red wall if this this
prime minister if it is going to be liz
trust she is going to have the most
enormously difficult task politically
but look that's nothing as difficult as
some families are going to face in
trying to pay their energy bills and
feed their families at the same time
because unless the government come up
with the right package they're not going
to be able to do both
yeah kevin it's interesting isn't it
there's the politics of all of this but
then there is the reality for people
living through this cost of living
crisis and it is not just biting it is
taking chunks out of families incomes
and we're talking about this pressure on
this trust or rishi sunak whatever
whatever whoever becomes the new prime
minister next week to take immediate
action now if you talk to um the
chancellor for example at the moment
nadine sahabi he says he's working night
and day
for these plans to come into fruition on
day one boris johnson the prime minister
says you know work is being done right
now so in the theory there should be a
plan come monday when the name is pulled
out of a hat as it were and how much
credence do you give to those claims
coming from the conservative party
because you know they might be electing
a new leader but this party is in
government it is meant to be functioning
and working for people right now yeah i
think the uh you said meant isn't it it
hasn't been it's been a zombie
government the demons have always just
been on a photo call to the us boris
johnson's on his
farewell tour just wearing a collection
of uniforms like mr ben in the old
cartoon series of the 1970s
going one door dress one way come out
another dress
very differently liz trust needs a plan
and she is at the moment she's a woman
without a plan she's a red hot favorite
to be the next prime minister to be
installed in in number 10 without
general election by the conservative
party
energy bills are a burning issue because
they are ruining family finances and
causing incredible concern and hardship
but she hasn't produced a plan where she
soon produced a plan labor the lib dems
smp have come up with a plan by freezing
the uh the energy gap she has not got a
plan because i think in part she
promised to reverse the corporation tax
rise which which is means
it'll be a big boom to
business as he said that's 17 that's 17
billion then she's going to reverse the
increase in national insurance well half
of that's already been spent in raising
the limit for national insurance and
both would give most money to those who
are on the highest incomes when the
people who will really be destroyed by
the energy prices are those on lower
incomes uh and actually some middle and
middle income people too
and where is her plan it won't get on
monday but will she be able to stand on
the
steps of downing street or
up in balmoral after she's seen the
queen on tuesday assuming she wins
and not come up with a plan
and that's why the the pressure is
is building on her what will you do but
she's already committed to spending so
much money on other tax uh cuts as she
she would put it a lot of spending plans
have been produced as well she's gone
around the country promising every local
area something might never see it but
nevertheless she's promised it but what
will she do on energy bills it's a big
challenge for i think it's why she
dodged the bbc interview on tuesday
night with
nick robinson
because she hasn't got a plan or she's
got a plan she's not telling us what
that plan is i don't think she's got a
plan the noises are she hasn't got a
worked out plan yet on the big issue
well whatever the plan ends up being
andrew it's going to have to be at some
scale isn't it because i'm just looking
inside the metro newspaper and this
report that's come out from the
resolution foundation saying real
earnings are on course to fall
10
um
saying we've had a decade of austerity
we've had a pandemic that we managed
badly uh there's inequality and now is
the cost of living crisis i was talking
to a landlord on sky news earlier this
week who said look you know i own a pub
that is over 200 years old we've seen
wars the covid pandemic was a doddle
compared to what we're going through now
we could close next month this really is
you can't underestimate the crisis that
people are facing
yeah and and the fact is small
businesses in particular have been
almost forgotten in this now um
the the the proposal by kierstarma the
labour leader to freeze energy prices is
popular it's very expensive he's only
cost it for six months uh but it doesn't
include small businesses they've been
forgotten here and pubs and cafes and
restaurants they're going to face huge
increases in fuel and energy bills
they're already and already they've got
the cost of food is soaring as well not
least because of the problems in ukraine
so that's got to be part of whatever the
government brings forward in the next
week or so because pubs
uh are part of the english of of the
british heritage they're part of the
part of the way we we do things they
many of them were knocked out of
business during the pandemic despite the
furlough
they've just come back it's been very
difficult and now they've been whacked
with this the price of alcohol is going
up the price of everything's going up
inflation over 10 percent so um the the
package of immediate
measures emergency measures to help
families also have to address small
businesses because it's not just pubs
it's all sorts of small businesses are
worrying how they're going to pay their
bills
yeah kevin what's your view on that
you know businesses have been very clear
about what the government can do to help
them survive cut business rates help
them out with
vat
how is what they're going through now
different to the covert pandemic they
received help then why is it different
now why are they not getting the same
kind of attention it's just as dangerous
for their livelihoods
it is sergey it's because the government
hasn't come up with a covet style
response it's treating it as just a bit
of an economic turbulence when it is not
and it does require something like the
the the co the code response otherwise
these business businesses will be
they'll be destroyed i mean this is a
huge threat to them as it is well to
households but the resolution foundation
they're talking about the biggest
squeeze for a 100 years on incomes by
2023-24
typical family will have lost a typical
household lost 3 000 pounds that's a 10
percent fall in income that is just
unprecedented it's uh inflation's 10.1
percent now goldman sachs were
predicting it was going to go into 2022
it's why there's pressure and disputes
over over pay if i was on strike at the
daily mirror today as as part of the
reach uh strike
because i'm a member of the national
union of journalist over a three percent
pay offer which would just mean a lot of
a lot of my colleagues particularly
those on lower wages i'll just see their
living standards absolutely destroyed
and they will not know how
to cope
so
the government in in a sense
i just think hasn't got the scale
of the of the problem and yes it's gonna
cost money in in
some ways to to uh to resolve and
alleviate uh and you can either let
people suffer individually or you can
collectively take
interventions by by the government it'll
have to be paid off of course down the
line but you can manage that
while at the moment it's
particularly with truss she just i just
i just think really she hasn't got it
and she's going to pay a high political
price the conservative
party that cult 160 000 might like what
she says but it doesn't look like the
rest of the country does because people
people are suffering and can see it's
going to get worse not better yeah well
we don't know yet and we've got to give
a time because uh she she she if you if
she's
she can't be well hang on exactly that's
the point she can't she can't appear to
presumptuous because she hasn't won it
yet she can't announce a budget uh uh
while she's foreign secretary she's not
prime minister so we do have to give a
time and it's not her fault we've got
this ridiculous system whereby it's
taking the tories longer to elect a tory
leader and prime minister than it does a
country they're going to have to change
this voting system next time we cannot
possibly go through this again it's far
too long it's ridiculous i mentioned it
earlier they call it a race it's more
like a marathon and i just want to talk
about something else the resolution
foundation and put out in their report
and it's made the front page of the
guardian they're talking about thousands
of extra child deaths occurring um
if families are forced to turn off their
heating we talk about the cost of the
government of dealing with this crisis
but this headline focuses on the far
bigger cost andrew if they don't do
something about it
yeah and let's pray to god that we um
that we have a mild winter uh because if
it's a very cold winter and families
can't afford to turn the heating on and
there will already be people not doing
that
it's talking this report says that
babies partic young children who are
already potentially malnourished in
low-income families families perhaps
where they don't manage money very well
and let's not forget very very old
people too will be impacted by this and
it could lead to a really really
terrifying spike surge in um deaths that
wouldn't normally happen
um it forecasts that three million more
people will be living in absolute
poverty a relative child poverty
will hit its highest level since the
peaks of the 1990s in a frankly
terrifying outlook
for living standards kevin just want to
get your thoughts on that
it starts it's a stark headline isn't it
it is it's the country going backwards
not forwards and we we've got to be able
to do better than this i think we can do
better than this and the report on kids
is the institute health equity it's
incredibly well respected director sir
michael uh marmot who is a
a real expert on the on the impact of
inequality and he's backed by a
consultant at alder hey hospital in in
liverpool and we will damage the life
prospects of kids for
decades to come
because their parents their families
their carers won't be able to afford to
heat their homes properly and it's not
just put on another jumper as you
occasionally hear people say look this
is people who won't be able to put
heating on at all and if you if you're
shivering you'll be you'll be both
physically and emotionally damaged by
that you won't be able to concentrate
at the same time you won't have money to
eat properly
uh most of other live social life
contact will
come to an end this is this is a real
crisis i mean it goes back you say why
isn't there a covered style response i
mean that that is the big feeling of the
government it just hasn't got a grip of
the skills
as andrew pointed out you know give them
time
kevin keeps reading a crystal ball he
doesn't know yet who does not know
andrew she is you do not know kevin you
do not know because we haven't got a
prime minister who is doing anything at
the moment we're getting a new prime
minister next week give her a chance
trust has come up with what she would do
on corporation tax what you would do on
national insurance what you would do
with everything
your major come up with a plan that's
uncosted and will help rich people as
much as poor people
his plan
that freeze that um cap freeze
kevin will help you won't it
yeah well well we we are gonna have to
wait until tuesday those those are just
the rules we're gonna have to wait until
next week that those are the rules uh i
don't make them up but um i just want to
talk about the queen before we head to
the break andrew front page of the daily
express a resting queen won't risk
reaching the new pm in london the
queen's on holiday uh so the outgoing
prime minister and the incoming prime
minister are going to have to go up to
scotland to see her
yeah look if she wasn't so frail and if
she wasn't suffering mobility issues and
if she wasn't 96 she would come down to
buckingham palace which is that what is
the normal procedure for the prime
minister it's the constitutional
propriety but the outgoing prime
minister goes to see her the new one
goes to see her afterwards so they'll
both go to balmoral what i want to know
is do they go together on a plane
together because oh to be a flying the
wall with boris johnson and blizzcross
on the plane going up i suspect uh boris
goes up on the um
the the royal flight which is shared by
the prime minister and politicians and
comes back on easyjet liz treska liz
trust goes up in easyjet and comes back
on the roll flight
it's unusual it's the first time it's
ever happened before uh uh but i don't
mind it uh kevin will rage and moan
about it being an outrage
well look we're running out of time i'll
get kevin's thoughts on that story after
eleven o'clock but uh i'd like to thank
you for ending that
we'll be back we'll be back plenty more
to say after this short break coming up
boris johnson weighing in on the legacy
of russia's last soviet leader in the
light of the ongoing war in ukraine
[Music]
hello welcome back you are watching the
press preview with me now consultant
editor at the daily mail andrew pearce
an associate editor of the daily mirror
kevin mcguire and we're going to go
straight to
a story in the metro and it is about
mikhail gorbachev
and his legacy the prime minister boris
johnson amongst a number
of world leaders paying tribute today
and but it was interesting kevin he said
that um vladimir putin essentially is on
his own mission to undo all of the work
uh mikhail gorbachev put in place and
ultimately destroy his legacy yeah to be
a czar and resurrect a a russian empire
because of course the
the ussr the soviet union collapsed
under gorbachev's program of perestroika
and glasnost and
the cold war was ended peacefully and
poland could be poland hungary hungary
baltic states public state ukraine
ukraine and we know that gorbachev
because of his family connections to
ukraine uh very much opposed the uh
unprovoking invasion by
putin but at the same time i think what
johnson doesn't grasp
is that gorbachev also opposed and
believe he had
undertakings that nato would not expand
onto russia's border by taking in those
former parts of the soviet soviet union
nato so i'm not sure johnson really gets
what uh what what you know what happened
in partly gorbachev's legacy in
in russia although he was pushed aside
so it happened under
yeltsin who was just a drunken corrupt
uh incompetent idiot
was the pillaging of that country's
incredible asset by uh oligarchs and the
west itself just encouraging what became
casino capitalism which impoverished and
made poor so many
russians who at first harked back to
communism and regrets its passing and
then became incredibly
nationalist and thought goldberg was
guilty of a terrible national
humiliation which is why putin has more
support within russia than we sometimes
concede or
acknowledge
um andrew it's fallen to you i did
wonder who
i was going to have enough time for to
to give this story to you this is the
front page of the daily star uh why our
3 billion pound navy ship broke down
forgive me if i don't read the
headline well this is our great our
great
aircraft carrier it on it's i don't know
if it's quite it's made involved when
it's first voyage but the stars put it
rather tackly but somebody apparently
didn't grease
um a certain part of the ship's anatomy
uh and the star has had great fun with
that headline i'm not sure if that is
the real reason but if it's true then um
i did see a very very interesting
letters in the times where by lord
admiral west who was um gordon brown's
sleep first sea lord saying it's still a
very impressive ship but somebody better
grease it back grease it better grease
it up